the survival game has gone from a
relatively niche genre to one with
massive mainstream appeal if you've
found yourself hooked and are looking
for some of the very best to dig into
then don't worry we've got you covered
here are 19 of the best survival games
instead of a more traditional movement
system you'd expect from a first person
action title dying light makes heavy use
of parkour mechanics to allow for daring
escapes that really emphasize the danger
of a swarm of zombies much better than a
game where you can just blast your way
through the entire horde that doesn't
mean you can't still deliver some pain
to the zombies with a variety of weapons
like hammers bows and shotguns but the
balance of fight or flight creates
something we just don't see in many
other open world zombie games and it
exemplifies survival better than many
games that take a more traditional
approach to the genre
how could any survival game list not
include minecraft not only is it one of
the most influential and successful
video games ever made but it's also
still damn good a decade after its
launch the procedurally generated world
is filled or can be filled with plenty
of unexpected areas including veins of
valuable materials and clusters of
enemies and it's up to you to decide how
to protect yourself from the monsters
and exploding creepers that threaten
your survival of course if you want a
break you can always go into creative
mode and focus exclusively on building
the structure of your dreams instead
when it first launched in 2016 no man's
sky was a shell of a game most of its
best systems weren't even created yet
and the prospect of exploring for the
sake of exploring didn't exactly thrill
many players but hello games didn't give
up implementing base building
multiplayer and a variety of other
quality of life improvements to make no
man's sky the ultimate space exploration
game finding new wildlife establishing
your operations on a planet and seeing
what it has to offer all while
monitoring your life support systems now
feels satisfying and fulfilling and
continued updates have only made the
game even better since then it's one of
gaming's biggest redemption stories and
the initial reception shouldn't turn you
off from playing it
escape from tarkov is a much more
complex game than you'd think with some
interesting twists of its own in
addition to realistic injuries you must
account for things like fractures
hydration and blood loss you must
carefully protect your scavenged loot
because death also means dropping
everything you've acquired it's not
exactly an mmo but with a player-driven
economy for looted items the risk and
reward dynamic in escape from tarkov
adds an extra layer of tension to every
battle meaning you'll need to watch out
for deteriorating weapons lest you have
a gun jam right before you're shot in
the face of course that can also happen
to your enemy
rust has had an interesting journey in
early development it seemed too eager to
imitate other survival games even
including zombies at one point but it
gradually established its own identity
as a straightforward and addictive
survival game with an island full of
wildlife and other players the latter of
whom can either help or hurt you you
need to be always on your toes and
finding allies you are comfortable with
can be the difference between life and
death thanks to a relatively recent
popularity surge caused by streamers the
game has gotten a second wind and there
is even a separate console addition if
you don't have a pc
getting mauled to death by land
creatures is scary enough but there is
little more terrifying than dying
underwater in subnautica you have no
choice but to venture into the murky
depths of a watery planet in order to
survive and ironically you still need to
find water to drink because salt water
will only kill you faster you'll have a
chance to upgrade your vessel's hull in
order to protect it from the increasing
pressure as you venture deeper into the
abyss and you can even establish bases
and build other vehicles to assist you
in your research and exploration this
isn't a simple survive game however with
a mystery to uncover at its core so
those who aren't into the basic don't
die gameplay loop may still enjoy
subnautica
a surprise hit on steam that managed to
outperform some of the biggest pc games
valheim scratches the survival game itch
without being locked into some of the
genre's core elements the fantasy game
puts you in a procedurally generated
world where you can work cooperatively
with up to nine other players and you
can build a house and even an entire
settlement alongside smaller items like
weapons armor food and seeing as this is
a norse world mede the combat is also a
little bit more advanced than similar
survival games with mechanics for
dodging and blocking attacks and you can
also venture out into the sea and test
your skills as the captain of a vessel
it's only 20 bucks and with the hearth
and home update adding even more content
to the game including new furniture and
food items it's a very refreshing take
on survival
ark survival evolved certainly
emphasizes the survival element of its
name in addition to the common survival
game mechanics such as hunger and thirst
systems you must also contend with
shifting weather conditions that can
cause your health to deteriorate even
faster as well as both wildlife and
other players sticking together can be
the key to survival through the game's
tribe system and you can also tame and
train dangerous dinosaurs which can
assist in hunting or even be used as
mounts when you have to fend off
attackers if you prefer you can even
rely on farming produce to survive
without killing though your enemies may
not be quite as kind to you
don't starve well that title gets right
to the point doesn't it a take on
resource gathering and crafting that
doesn't waste time with unnecessary
preamble or extra fluff don't starve's
mix of 2d and 3d art makes it unlike any
other game on this list and combined
with its addictive gameplay loop and
punishing difficulty it will certainly
test your ability to adapt and overcome
with procedurally generated worlds you
will never experience the same game
twice in a row and the standalone
expansion don't starve together lets you
and your friends try and make it in the
cold unforgiving world as a group
to survive you must always be one step
ahead of whatever it is that wants to
kill you in the case of the flame in the
flood that includes not just predators
but the elements as well as you travel
in a boat down a river and try to
outpace impending rain you'll come
across towns that you can scavenge for
supplies to keep yourself alive during
the journey but this can lead to
unintended encounters with the local
wildlife the flame in the flood's dark
premise is contrasted by its gorgeous
minimalist art style as well as a
beautiful americana driven soundtrack
even the most morbid difficult moments
are still somewhat calming at least up
until you die and have to try again
a survival game that also combines
elements of horror and cooperative open
world exploration the forest features a
fish out of water setup in which you're
hunted by genetically mutated locals
while trying to survive the wilderness
the choice for how you do this is up to
you ranging from creating a robust
fortress or sneaking around to take out
the attackers stealthily like other
survival games such as minecraft there
is a day night cycle encouraging you to
explore and scavenge while it's light
before retreating to the safety of your
shelter at night with friends by your
side things can be a little less
daunting but you'll still need to find
food if you don't want to die by
starvation and that's just as terrifying
as the enemies
in the long dark another game that sees
the world plunged into constant winter
you must venture out alone searching for
your companion after you're separated
the separate survival mode offers more
freedom with surviving as long as
possible being your only goal and
permadeath looming over every decision
you make with every action you make you
spend calories that must be replenished
with food but the threat of the elements
always balances out your need to go find
more resources
outward may look like a sword and
sorcery power fantasy at first glance
but you actually play as a pretty
pathetic little weakling even a disease
can spell the end for you in outward
alongside thirst and no playthrough will
ever be exactly the same the game also
makes sure you don't manipulate its
systems by constantly auto saving in a
similar manner to an mmo but with
perseverance and some careful planning
you can become a hero if you want you
can even join a friend both in person or
online and attempt to not get killed by
the most trivial of enemies together
11 bit studios frostpunk is a society
survival game that sees a world plunged
entirely into an endless winter it's up
to you to keep your civilization from
death managing resources and
establishing laws that will prevent
total chaos and anarchy while still
maintaining your people's health and
happiness the decisions you make can
have unintended and permanent
consequences both good and bad should
you rule smartly you can even invest in
advanced technologies returning people
to some degree of normalcy you don't
necessarily need some supernatural or
science fiction threat in order for the
apocalypse to feel terrifying
[Music]
if you took minecraft and turned it into
a 2d game it would look a whole lot like
terraria though the focus is on more
than just survival and building
structures here venturing into the deep
caverns of the randomly generated worlds
you explore could lead to rare resources
and materials to let you craft something
truly amazing or it might just make for
a great anecdote about the dangerous
areas you encountered instead
enjoy city building games but wish you
had more control over individual people
and didn't have to deal with boring old
earth surviving mars might be just what
you're looking for then as the game has
you build up an early human colony on
the titular planet while also having to
deal with the people who make up your
civilization each one has its own ai
meaning you won't be able to make
universal sweeping decisions that have
the same impact on everyone and their
problems can become your problems if you
don't manage them efficiently but it's
more than just survival as you can
discover the hidden mysteries of mars
itself some of which may not be pleasant
a survival game that should be right up
the alley of any prison architect fans
rimworld follows a small group of
unwilling colonists who've crashed onto
a new planet and must attempt to rebuild
and thrive in their serendipitous
situation they aren't alone on the
planet with raiders and wildlife alike
seeking their heads but you can also
tame your own beasts to do your bidding
and set up defensive positions to blast
anyone who comes close
injuries and disease are tracked to
specific body parts and you can even get
a prosthetic limb if need be and combat
isn't just based on stats instead there
is an actual cover system you can
manipulate through your structure's
placement and design
one of the darkest games on this list
because it sheds fantasy and sci-fi for
the realistic horrors of war this war of
mine puts you in control of the
civilians caught in the middle of an
armed conflict unable to escape danger
and merely hoping to survive by the time
the battles have ended you'll need to
gather basic supplies to survive but the
risk of being caught in the crossfire
can deter you from getting what you
actually need and the decisions you need
to make aren't easy who is worth
sacrificing for the good of the group
and can such a choice even be made
fully customizable and with enough
difficulty options for every kind of
player starbound mixes sci-fi
exploration and adventure with survival
elements to create a charming and
inspired take on the genre there isn't a
set end goal though you can find your
own victory by battling enemies or
venturing out to take over other planets
on the hardcore difficulty setting
you'll need to eat to survive and if you
die you're dead for good while survival
difficulty replaces this with an item's
drop on death feature for a little more
flexibility with mod support further
letting you personalize the experience
start bound is quite literally what you
make of it
so there you have it 19 of the best
survival games around for more lists
like this one including the best open
world games to play right now make sure
you're subscribed to gamespot thanks for
watching
[Music]
you